tirait pratiquement au quotidien sur la
ville de sarajevo en 95 la ville est
déjà assiégée depuis trois ans la
population est donc soumise à une
pression d'une rare violence donc
rappelé nous un petit peu les tenants et
les aboutissants de ce conflit d'un jeu
je vais faire bref mais en 91 la
fédération yougoslave explose en
commençant par la slovénie assez
rapidement le la bosnie herzégovine
quand il revendique son autonomie et son
indépendance et les serbes s'y oppose
violemment est une des actions clés de
ce conflit a été le siège de sarajevo
d'abord parce qu'il ya très peu de
sièges de ville dans l'époque
contemporaine
et en plus cela une ville au coeur de
l'europe tout le monde a entendu parler
de sarajevo par les jeux olympiques par
les vacances par etc
la ville va être assiégé pendant plus de
quatre ans quand j'arrive en 95 la ville
est déjà assiégée depuis trois ans donc
il faut imaginer une population qui est
entièrement encerclée la notion qu'on
connaît plus depuis des décennies depuis
trois ans qui peut plus sortir librement
ou se faire approvisionner dans la ville
et qui en plus est soumise à des tirs
quasi quotidiens
et d'ailleurs c'est pour ça que j'ai
j'ai appelé mon livre vent glacial sur
sarajevo parce que ce vent glacial c'est
ce que j'ai ressenti quand j'ai compris
que la mission pour laquelle nous étions
venus n'était pas celle à laquelle nous
nous étions préparés et que nous étions
pris au piège donc j'ai voulu raconter
dans un récit très réaliste ce qui s'est
passé pendant ce cette intervention là
et parce qu'on aurait aimé qu'il se
passe j'ai pris le temps de raconter mes
compagnons d'armes ces soldats
professionnels leur courage de raconter
aussi ces situations inextricables et
cette capitale assiégée que nous n'avons
pas su protéger
votre mission consistait à dézinguer les
canons d'artillerie en les illuminant
pour des frappes aériennes
qu'est ce qui s'est passé sur type
d'opération ça aller jusqu'au bout il ya
eu 2 des pièces d'artillerie qui ont été
d un gi pas d un geek comment ça se
passait là en fait la mission bien sûr
et candia s'intégrer dans ce mandat
d'interposition de l'onu un l'onu avait
une mission pour limiter les dégâts
essayé de séparer les belligérants donc
les serbes assiègent la ville de
sarajevo
si je peux me permettre d'ouvrir une
parenthèse donc ce type de missions vous
autorise à bombardier hooper oui
absolument c'est à dire que les
conditions d'engagement particulière qui
avait été réglé dans le cas d'un accord
sous l'égide de l'onu et aucune arme
lourde ne devait plus être utilisés
autour de la ville donc les armes
lourdes étaient censées être stockées
sous contrôle de l'onu et si une d'elles
était utilisée elle aurait dû être
immédiatement détruites ça c'est la
mission donc la mission était finalement
relativement simple on avait à ce moment
là une armada aérienne absolument
inimaginable depuis la deuxième guerre
mondiale et plus de 450 avions de combat
fournies par l'otan et au service de
l'onu et nous nous devions nous assurer
que cet accord était pleinement
respectés sachant que si un canon tirés
sur la ville on devait c'était l'objet
de mon équipe le localiser être sûr que
voilà c'était bien une bonne cible et
qu'on fasse pas une erreur dramatique et
la détruire ça c'était l'objet s'est
jamais simple mais c'était l'objet de la
mission la réalité c'est ce que j'ai
voulu décrire dans mon livre c'est que
ça n'a jamais fonctionné
et ça n'a jamais fonctionné
dans une espèce de confusion qui a été
soigneusement entretenu c'est à dire que
l'image qu'ont souvent les français de
cette situation c'est que c'est
tellement bordélique l'onu qu'au fond on
pouvait pas attendre d'elle une décision
une application sur le terrain la
réalité que je décris tout autre c'est
que pendant cette période là alors je ne
parle que de ce que j'ai fait dont je
parle de sarajevo du siège de sarajevo
de la mission que j'effectue et
les ce sont des français qui
verrouillaient tous les postes clés dans
la force de protection de l'onu jusqu'à
son plus haut niveau et qu'en fait cette
force avait une politique officielle
affichée qui était celle bien sûr de du
mandat de l'onu s'interposer dans le cas
du siège
mais dont la réalité
l empêcher qu'on s'en prenne aux serbes
d'une part de par l'affection que la
france a avec un de ses anciens alliés
très honnêtement je ne connais pas les
raisons puisque elles n'ont jamais été
expliqués d'ailleurs cette politique n'a
jamais été affichés officiellement nous
sommes venus pour empêcher les
agresseurs d'assiéger la ville en tout
cas pour les empêcher d'utiliser des
armes l'eau et dans la réalité on nous a
interdit de s'en prendre aux agresseurs
et ça nous a mis dans une situation
absolument invraisemblable parce que non
seulement 11 et le contraire de ce pour
quoi nous étions venus mais essayez
d'imaginer un shérif qu'on envoie dans
le saloon en lui disant coco tu rentres
tu remets de l'ordre mais par contre on
enlève les munitions ton pistolet alors
qu'en face les mecs qui sont armés
jusqu'aux dents donc non seulement on
n'a pas pu protéger la vie ça c'est je
crois ce dont je vais m'en veut le plus
mais en plus assez rapidement on s'est
mis en danger en grand danger en tout
cas mes équipes sont mises en danger
parce que les serbes ont vite compris
qu'on s'en prendrait pas eu et comme
nous étions le dernier obstacle pour
pouvoir entrer dans la ville on était
localisé sur l'aéroport de sarajevo qui
était le verrou de la ville
on est devenu une forme de cible dans ce
conflit et on a nous mêmes étaient
assiégés à un moment par les serbes ce
qui peut sembler complètement paradoxale
j'ai trouvé inouïe que dans cette
situation on intervient dans un siège
nous mêmes on se retrouve assiégé par
une des factions voilà je pense qu'on
était allé au bout de l'absurdité et au
bout de l'ambiguïté d'une politique
parce que là c'était clairement une
politique de la france donc je n'imagine
pas de seconde qui est un officier
français qui ai décidé d obéir à un
mandat c'est pas si c'est pas de ce
niveau là ça c'est une décision
politique qui était à la tête de tous à
l'époque alors à l'époque qui est un
gouvernement de cohabitation qui
complique singulièrement les choses
présidée par françois mitterrand le
secrétaire général de l'elysée qui joue
sûrement un rôle clé dans la sphère et
hubert védrine et le gouvernement et
balladur avec françois léotard comme
ministre de la défense et alain juppé
comme ministre des affaires étrangères
lanxade dans la boucle alors moi je
parle des responsables politiques
après il ya sûrement des personnes qui
ont joué un rôle très important entre ce
niveau là qui a la légitimité politique
de prendre les décisions mais qui
paradoxalement ne les a jamais affiché
et donc encore moins expliquer alors que
je me permets d'insister sûr ce point ce
sont des interventions qui ont été
menées au nom de la france mais met ses
responsables politiques ce sont des
douanes et de la moindre explication sur
la politique qu'on avait appliqué à ce
sujet et dans leur entourage il y avait
sûrement des personnages qui ont joué un
rôle clé comme l'amiral lanxade mais
dont j'ignore le rôle réel dans la
mesure où moi ce que je décris c'est
vraiment l'aspect opérationnel c'est à
dire la réalité sur le terrain est ce
que je veux montrer à travers mon livre
c'est le décalage qu'il ya entre la
version officielle c'est l'onu on
comprend rien et c est la réalité qui
est non on nous a lié les mains alors
qu'en fait on avait tout ce qu'il
fallait pour empêcher les canons serbe
ne tirer sur la ville et on les a
laissés consciencieusement matraque et
la ville jusqu'à ce que cette politique
change brutalement et pas du fait de la
france on va rentrer un peu plus dans le
détail de votre cuisine opérationnel
votre journée type de boulot quand vous
étiez à l'armée parce que vous êtes
sortis de l'armée en tant que lieutenant
colonel c'était en 2005 c'est ça il ya
douze ans à chevalier de l'ordre de la
légion d'honneur c'est ça à titre
militaire
donc vous vous illuminer les cibles on
va prendre la technologie de 1994
sarrasine s'arrête un peu
ça consiste en quoi vous approcher au
plus près des lignes ennemies vous avez
un grenadier voltigeur avec vous vous
avez quoi vous êtes combien de personnes
on rentre un peu dans les tailles de
deux solutions monsieur c'est en fait
c'est une pratique assez délicate dans
la mesure où on a rapidement compris que
nos avions de chasse peuvent
difficilement taper à coup sûr sur des
cibles dans des environnements complexes
voilà sinon on se fait l'ambassade de
chine comme c'est arrivé dans un
bombardement à belgrade et art assez ya
une histoire vous avez déjà été à
belgrade un peu et très peu c'est
intéressant de voir l'ambassade de chine
comme on a été bombardé et puis aussi la
radio et la télévision or je réponds à
votre question la précision de frappe
avec vous c'est combien ça chirurgicale
comme il faut ça dépend théoriquement
ces dix mètres dans la réalité c'est
toujours beaucoup plus compliqué parce
que typiquement donc à 900 km heure un
avion de grande chance alors qu'il passe
que quelques jours on en fait au dessus
de sa cible et la grande chance de se
planter donc pour empêcher des erreurs
tragiques on met une équipe au sol très
proche de la cible pas toujours dans une
zone qu'on contrôle donc avec une
espérance de vie d'autant plus limité
que là où les avions vont rester 20
secondes au dessus de leurs objectifs et
quelques minutes dans la zone l'équipe
elle elle va rester plusieurs heures et
forcément elle est très discrète sauf
qu'une fois que le bombardement que les
avions sont passés tout le monde a
compris qu'elle était là donc elle est
candidate elle doit avoir un
instinct de survie assez développé et
donc ce sont des équipes qui sont
entraînés pour être discrète
très bonne observatrice parce qu'il faut
trouver sur le terrain où sont
réellement les objectifs on a des
indications mais on n'est pas toujours
tout à fait sûr on est beaucoup de
surprises et surtout réagir très vite
parce que l'action dure quelques
secondes donc il faut être capable de
coordonner les avions qui arrivent à
toute vitesse et qui sont pressés de pas
rester trop longtemps les troupes au sol
pour être sûr que l avance pas au moment
où on va bombarder ou le contraire et
donc ça nécessite une bonne capacité de
coordination et cette équipe à l'époque
c'était six personnes ce sont des
équipes de gens en général très
entraînés très expérimenté faut
plusieurs années pour être sûr sur ses
fonctions des deux contrôleurs avancer
ou pour être chef de taille puisque
était mon cas pour une chef de l'équipe
et on a des sous-officiers avec nous que
son remarquable de maîtrise technique de
l'éclairage laser en passant par tous
les types d'armes et de véhicules qu'on
puisse utiliser qui sont aussi au
passage infirmiers etc c'est donc le but
de cette équipe c'est de se rapprocher
de la cible suffisamment pour pouvoir
la guider les avions de suçons
les erreurs et ensuite pour guider les
avions utilise plusieurs techniques en
général on double en fait on fait un
guidage visuel les avions restent en
haute altitude à plus de 3 km d'altitude
dont personne ne les voit et on les
emmène sur la cible en leur faisant un
parcours visuel
pendant que les avions sur un hippodrome
pour regarder ce qui se passe en dessous
d'eux et parallèlement on éclaire la
cible avec un faisceau laser qui n'est
pas visible à l'oeil nu mais qui leur
permet d'avoir une sur précision au
moment du tir en général on cumule les
deux parce que on a noté que dans ces
opérations aucun système n'est
totalement fiable et le but c'est de
limiter la marge d'erreur et surtout
c'est ça le la complexité un petit peu
de ses équipes c'est que c'est elle
qu'il prenne la responsabilité de la
frappe dire que le pilote toute la
responsabilité technique c'est lui qui a
le doigt sur le bouton pour lancer les
en général sont des munitions une idée
des bombes ou des who des missiles mais
c'est le tapis qui doit décider si la
frappe est opportune ou pas et donc à
partir du moment où il donne son
autorisation
ce qu'on appelle un
autre oeil seulement à ce moment-là un
client de rhodes pardon je vais prendre
les aidant les dans le jargon danse
jargon militaire les avions
l'autorisation le frapper mais en fait
la responsabilité a été prise par
l'équipe au sol donc s'il ya des petits
enfants qui sont morts pour apporter la
démocratie pour les petites filles c'est
la faute de celui qui est au sol oui
tout à fait c'est sa responsabilité
d'estimer quelles sont les dommages
collatéraux qui risque dans une frappe
et est ensuite normalement sauf s'il a
des instructions particulières si à lui
de décider si elle est faisable ou pas
donc vous savez
vous connaissez la technicité de larmes
qui va être envoyé
son pouvoir de neutralisation de
destruction la destruction
l'uranium appauvri en serbie ça pose un
problème d'envoyer une frappe à
l'uranium appauvri sur un territoire
civile
à cette époque à ma connaissance les
munitions à uranium appauvri avaient été
retirés du service d'assurance et je les
américaines ou les hôtels et
les palans les français dans n'utilisez
pas dans l'armé aérienne mais américain
les avait retiré parce que tout le monde
a eu un doute après la guerre du golfe
où elles ont été utilisées massivement
et où manifestement été observés des
syndromes médicaux inconnu et un doute
je crois qu'il n'a jamais été quand il
reconnu malheureusement mais comme par
hasard les munitions alors les français
on avait des munitions à uranium
appauvri dans les chars elles ont toutes
été retirés du service et les américains
à ma connaissance en 95 avec les à 10
dans n'utilisez plus donc c'est moins le
cas de ces munitions que le fait que
quand on frappe avec une arme c'est
forcément pour détruire et donc
forcément il va y avoir des morts je
connais aucune arme qui n'est pas fait
pour tuer si ça fait des morts sur
plusieurs trentaine dizaines centaines
d'années derrière par des cancers ou des
choses comme ça est ce qu'il ya des
salles de ce problème d'état d'âme
cette question là ça vous est déjà
arrivé de coordonner une frappe
chimiques n'ont jamais j'ai vous savez
faire un nom à ma connaissance on
n'utilisait pas d'armes chimiques dont
que le temps est ce que vous avez été
formés pour ce type de bus non nous n'en
avions pas cette époque en utiliser les
armes chimiques étaient interdites dans
l'armée française donc on les
connaissait on connaissait les mesures
passives les mesures de protection ce
qu'on avait peur qu'elle soit utilisée
contre nous mais on n'a jamais
coordonnées de frappe sur ni avec des
armes chimiques ni avec des armes
nucléaires parce qu'une arme nucléaire
est tellement puissante qu'on évite de
laisser une équipe de guidage à quelques
kilomètres de la cible sauf si elle veut
avoir une espérance de vie cette fois
vraiment limité pour compléter son
bronzage
et
cancon pardon j'ai pas terminée sur un
point parce que ça fait partie du
guidage il faut imaginer ce moment très
impressionnant ou en a repéré la cible
je vais prendre un exemple concret un
chariot est ce que c'est un truc que je
relate dans mon livre on cherche des
pièces d'artillerie on pense qu'elles
sont sur une colline mais on les voit
pas on a fait passer des avions de
surveillance là rien dessus on n'a rien
simplement il ya des équipes de
légionnaires qui a entendu plutôt qu'ils
nous ont relaté des signes suspects il
trouve qu' il y avait une activité
anormale entendu des sifflements exemple
voilà ils ont suffisamment d'indicés un
peu comme une enquête policière pour
nous orienter nos recherches donc on est
là en observation d'un des systèmes
optiques très est très puissante et on
voit à rien sur cette colline play luca
huit chats et puis d'un seul coup il ya
un rayon de soleil et là on s'aperçoit
simplement par l'ombre projetée du
boudin canon 10 cm alors on est à deux
kilomètres de distance on voit dix
centimètres dhombres qu en fait oui il
ya un objet métallique anormales sur une
colline comme ça il n'ya pas normalement
un truc et on découvre un canons
d'artillerie qui en fait est intégré
dans la colline qui a été enterrée la
nuit les serbes ont creusé des bunkers
et deux jours totalement camouflés y
compris aux caméras thermiques puisque
la terre protège fait écran donc on est
très content d'avoir trouvé ses canons
parce qu'on a là on a vraiment le voilà
matériellement pour des équipes comme
les notions hyper entraînés trouver une
cible ça veut dire on a rempli notre job
quoi et on va la détruire on est en
train de l'observer et là on et
halluciné le canon tirs sur la ville
donc non seulement on a trouvé un canon
serre mais en plus ils tirent sur la
ville on le voit aussi à la déflagration
avait une espèce de flamme orange avec
un léger décalage on entend le bruit
arriver et puis on se tourne un peu
inquiet pour voir où est ce que ce canon
a attiré souvent on ne voit pas un canon
peut tirer plusieurs kilomètres voire à
plusieurs dizaines de kilomètres hélas
les serbes sont en train de tirer sur la
sortie du tunnel que les bosniaques ont
creusé sous l'aéroport on voit un nuage
de fumée et je me suis un cette image
m'a marqué on voit au milieu du nuage de
fumée on voit un bus qui s'est élevé et
qui est en train de retomber donc il ya
plusieurs morts dans la vie des dizaines
de blessés
donc là on est exactement dans le cas
prévu par l'onu de les serbes utilisent
des armes lourdes contre la ville
destruction immédiate donc on passe par
un awacs pour faire venir immédiatement
une patrouille de chasseurs bombardiers
comme l'otan a mis en place un
dispositif hyper organisés on a une
patrouille d'avions dans les huit
minutes qui arrive je crois que c'est
des mirage 2000 qui descendent avec des
bombes guidées laser on est déjà comme
la cible on l'a parfaitement localisé et
identifié
on éclaire les prêts à faire un passage
et à ce moment là
j'entends à la radio stand-by
bizarre pas normal dans un truc comme ça
normalement on devrait même plus prendre
d'ordre on devrait détruire la cible et
on me rappelle à la radio pour me dire
que l'opération est annulée voilà ça
cette opération annulé on peut imaginer
une fois que c'est parce qu'on est en
train de discuter avec les crb que bonds
a dit d'arrêter à la dixième fois ça
devient un peu inquiétant est la
centième fois parce que j'ai dû guider à
peu près mon équipe pardon mon équipe a
dû guider à peu près une centaine de
frappes aériennes couture seriez vous
donc sans foi des canons ces aires qui
tire sur la ville et qu'on devrait
détruire sans fois ces opérations ont
été annulés cent fois on a fait
descendre des avions ce que les avions
sont à 3000 m d'altitude donc quand il
plonge sur l'a6 quand on donne
l'autorisation là ils s'exposent il
descend très bas pour être sûr de tirer
sur la possible héros monde il faut
savoir que pendant ces quelques dizaines
de secondes l'art les avions prennent
des risques énormes si jamais ils sont
tirés y compris par des baies de canon
mitrailleur etc il ya un vrai risque que
les avions soient battues d'ailleurs
c'est arrivé un peu plus tard pour un
mirage 2000 français donc il y a on
assure exploser des équipes
professionnelles pour une mission qu'en
fait on n'avait pas l'intention de mener
voilà et c'est pour ça que
j'estime que ce témoignage est important
parce que il n'interroge pas sur ce
qu'ont fait mes camarades mes compagnons
d'armes je vais admirer leur
professionnalisme ce que je ne comprends
pas ce sont des décisions politiques ont
été prises et qui joue typhi aucun
justifie rien d'ailleurs mais qu'ils
nous ont obligés à nous retrouver dans
cette situation est surtout le fait que
22 ans après on n'a toujours pas de
système de contrôle démocratique qui
permettrait d' exiger de savoir ce qui a
été fait au nom de la france surtout au
nom de l'argent public oui ça coûte du
pognon quand même un avion de chasse
chinois y en ait au passage quelques
hommes oui ou non mais les sommes
annoncées n'ont plus rien non on vous
avait dit qu'il est combien de
fonctionnaires de l'armée quand vous
étiez un curateur de 20000 il ya vingt
mille postes qu'on saute et
ça c'est un autre sujet quand on a un
qui n'a aucun rapport avec sarajevo
quand on a restructuré l'armée terre on
a
été obligé pratiquement de fermer les
deux tiers des bases qui existait
maintenant qu'est-ce que vous pensez de
l'ukraine de la syrie est ce que
l'expérience des balkans c'est une
question qui est internet de la
communauté lisa sur ce petit écran
est ce que l'expérience des balkans
peut-elle vous servir pour
comprendre analyser et agir sur le
terrain est ce que vous pensez qu'on a
eu une conduite en prospective sur ce
type de problème est juste avant
d'entendre votre réponse j'ai une
question concernant votre équipe à ce
que votre équipe a lu le bouquin
que vous allez sortir oui en partie oui
en partie
ce qu'ils vous ont demandé de ne pas
citer des noms est ce que ça leur a posé
des problèmes de se faire regarder à la
loupe par votre ancien employeur
alors je réponds à la deuxième question
et à la première ensuite comme vous
voulez
j'ai eu un retour qui m'a impressionné
mon livre a été publié il ya un petit
peu plus d'un mois
donc j'espère en avoir beaucoup mais en
gros j'ai une soixantaine de retour
jusqu'ici il ya un officier de légion
que je cite dans mon livre qui est
l'archétype de l'officier légion il a
fait l'essentiel de sa carrière dans la
légion étrangère s'était pas 1 10e
c'était plutôt un taiseux et il observé
tous étaient les choses très comme il
faut c'est celui qui dans l'eee
s'appelle-t-elle met et m'a envoyé
une seule ligne d'appréciation
guillaume virgule à la ligne merci pour
la justesse de ton témoignage points
signés jean louis point normal
vous avez vu les mecs quand on s'envoie
des mails non j'ai trouvé très
impressionnant et ça m'a fait plaisir
qu'ils prennent le temps de me dire ça
juste ça mais ça pour moi était énorme
ça veut dire que j'ai eu un sentiment à
travers ce témoignage non pas dire la
vérité mais un morceau de réalité j'ai
essayé de le faire avec exactitude et
justement en allant au fait pour ne pour
que quand on initiera enfin un débat que
j'espère d'idées sur pourquoi on a fait
ça et dans quel contexte et qui a
contrôlé les décisions qui ont été
prises sur le sujet on ne puisse pas
contester les pièces du pulse qui met
en
comment dire qu'ils contredisent
totalement la vérité officielle qui est
une fable sur le sujet alors on nous a
jamais raconté ce qui avait été fait
c'est pour ça que et là j'en arrive à la
deuxième car la première question
c'est très difficile de tirer une
expérience de quelque chose qu'on a
refusé de débriefer comme on n'a jamais
reconnu ce qui s'est passé à sarajevo
c'est compliqué d'apprendre je sais
qu'en interne parce que j étais dans les
armées on a eu des débats très intense
sur le sujet mais mes complexes parce
qu'il était interdit les exporter et il
était interdit d'écrire sur le sujet
mais il ya une liberté de parole au sein
des armées qui est assez étonnante
maintenant c'était des secrets
opérationnel et donc c'était normal
qu'on exporte pas tout
vingt ans après et l'âge ainsi sur ce
point on n'est pas sur un sujet de
secret opérationnel ou d'obligation de
réserve on est sur un sujet
d'intelligence collective et là on est
face en france à une culture du silence
qui est très française parce que dans
les armées anglo saxon cinq ans après
une opération les militaires raconte
comment ça s'est passé en réalité et
gare à celui surtout dans les décideurs
politiques qu'a raconté une fable parce
que lui se fait démonter voilà
les armes de destruction massive il
s'est pas trop fait démonter quand même
george bush n'ont cessé côté américain
sacrément il s'est fait sacrément
rappelez-vous simplement les films qui a
eu après par hollywood pour montrer que
tout ça c'était du beurre c'est inouï
c'est inimaginable en france qu' on
puisse avoir ce genre de production
alors déjà je trouvais qu'ils avaient
enfin moi j'ai lu la partie des livres
qui ont été publiés sur sarajevo pardon
mais les gens racontent la partie
émergée de l'iceberg
on a l'impression qu'ils s'interdisent
de raconter la réalité
je dire quelque chose de cruel la
plupart des militaires qui ont écrit sur
le sujet de sarajevo n'ont jamais osé
dire ce qu'ils pensaient en réalité ou
ce qui s'était passé en réalité il se
justifie à l'intérieur parce qu'ils ont
dû assumer la responsabilité de ce
qu'ils ont fait et ça les a mis dans une
situation très particulière moi j'estime
que c'est un devoir démocratique que de
raconter la réalité de ce qui s'est
passé après matin il m'appartient pas de
dire c'était bien où c'était ma je mens
je suis bien gardé dans mon livre je
fais pas une leçon dans mon livre je
raconte ce qui se passe ce que j'espère
c'est derrière il y aura un débat
politique et que les français pourront
juger en vrai mon livre en fait il est
destiné à ceux qui veulent se faire leur
propre opinion sur le sujet et qui en
ont assez qu'on leur dise qu'il faut
penser sur un sujet est ce que vous
considérez comme lanceur d'alerté
non je peins lanceur à l'être pardon je
ne suis pas un lanceur d alerte
je suis un empêcheur de transgresser
parce que j'estime que c'est une
transgression démocratique que prendre
des décisions au nom de la france et de
ne pas les expliquer aux français
vous avez fait un petit passage au
rwanda juste avant sarajevo et vous avez
selon vous eu des exactions du moins des
armements qui traînait dans des camps
qui ne fallait pas est-ce qu'on peut
rentrer un peu dans le détail
je vais faire simple moi je suis partie
au rwanda avec une unité de légion
étrangère quand j'étais détaché à
l'intérieur pour faire des frappes
aériennes
d'abord la première partie de la mission
qu'on a affiché comme étant humanitaire
nous nous sommes venus pour remettre au
pouvoir le gouvernement qu'on soutenait
léger décalage mais c'était notre
mission on s'est organisé pour le faire
on a été stoppée vraiment au dernier
moment mais pendant les huit premiers
jours de l'opération est pas question de
faire l'humanitaire était question d'une
opération de force pour reprendre le
pouvoir
quand enfin
le pouvoir de l'époque a pris conscience
que c'était peut-être un peu délicat de
remettre au pouvoir un gouvernement qui
organisait des massacres de très grande
ampleur attention à l'époque on parle
pas encore génocide on parle de massacre
de très grande ampleur me sont très
informés sur la l'ampleur des massacres
c'est combien au total ce sera entre 800
mille et un million de morts c'était
avant que ce soit considérée comme
génocide il était au courant de combien
de morts tom en amont la vie de
centaines de milliers leur services de
renseignement la dgse a très bien
fonctionné lors a parfaitement rendu ce
qui se passait sur le terrain et puis
honnêtement ce n'est pas la peine avoir
fait saint cyr pour comprendre quand on
arrive dans un territoire comme ça que
les tic en dix ans jusqu'au cou qui sont
autour de nous c'est eux qui ont commis
les massacres enfin voila c'était un peu
observable on a été projeté au milieu
donc voilà on le voyait on voyait que
les gens qui appartenait aux forces
gouvernementales que soit ce qui restait
de la police ou de l'armée inquiéter
souvent qui ressemblaient plus à des
milices était très très très très
impliquée dans les massacres donc
première partie on essaye de les
remettre au pouvoir quand on renonce
enfin les mettre au pouvoir on laisse
les membres de ce gouvernement
conseillers à des criminels on les
laisse s'échapper au zaïre et je dirais
presque on a quasiment protéger leur
fuite et au passage on les laisse à
organiser l'exode de leurs populations
cent mille morts supplémentaires il n'y
a pas eu des mesures françaises pour
éviter ça aucune je sais que des
officiers ont interrogé le pouvoir
appareils en dix ans peut-être que quand
même on pourrait au moins les
neutraliser les empêcher nuit enfin
c'est un peu bizarre de laisser des
grands qui me une aile de guerre passés
dans notre zone et puis leur assurer que
le passage de la frontière se fera sans
problème on nous a juste demandé de
s'assurer qu'il reste pas dans notre
zone mais pour le reste on nous a
demandé de ne pas les neutraliser sous
des raisons qui étaient quasiment
entendable c'est à dire on n'était pas
là pour faire la justice c'était pas
notre sujet voilà nous on était là pour
une mission particulière ont très bien
donc on les laisse on protège leur fuite
mais là et là à mon avis est
totalement
injustifiable j'ai assisté à une
livraison d'armes dans des camps de
réfugiés au zaïre on est quand même son
mandat humanitaire l'onu 1 il est censé
y avoir un embargo
à ces criminels c'est à dire qu'on leur
a livré des uns pour qu'ils puissent
continuer à se battre s'il croit que
ward c'était essentiellement des armes
légères celles qui étaient utilisés sur
le terrain c'est à dire des kalachnikov
des imitations d'un fusil israélien que
la plaie g4
toute la vous êtes en train de me dire
que bon temps en temps il ya des armes
qui peuvent s'est garé c'est ça ou
s'étaient livrés un lancer pas des armes
qui s'égare moi j'ai assisté à une
livraison d'armes c'est à dire un convoi
de containers gelé su parce qu'on m'a
demandé de détourner l'attention des
journalistes qui étaient sur nos d'oise
à ce moment là s'ils n'ont même pas dit
je pense que je n'aurais pas su et ce
qu'on voit da qui avait entre cinq et
dix camions partent et au zaïre dans les
camps de réfugiés pour rendre des as aux
forces gouvernementales
qui s'était enfui sur notre protection
et dont on pouvait lire au moins elles
pourront plus nuire c'est à dire c'est
devant un tribunal j'ai déjà été
auditionné par le pôle génocides du
tribunal de grande instance donc je suis
tout à fait prêt à le redire vous avez
eu un contrôle fiscal depuis
n'ont pas encore d'autres ennuis mais
pas ça quel type
avait pas forcément liés mais
monde et menaçant les grandes largeurs à
qui sort tout sur internet puisque
l'anonymat permet absolument tout c'est
quand même hallucinant de pouvoir se
comporter de cette manière ce saut
anonymat j'étais menacé physiquement bon
j'ai trouvé ça assez désagréable
physiquement comment au cce alors il ya
des choses qui sont assez fine quand il
ya des choses qui le sont moins
quand on prend un intermédiaire pour
vous signaler que c'est bien vous ayez
pas été écrasé sur un passage piéton
mais en fait c'est sans doute parce que
vous avez été trop publiés dans la
presse pour qu'on puisse se permettre de
faire ça vous comprenez que il faut
faire attention en traversant les
passages piétons que je savais être
dangereux dans paris d'ailleurs
l'autre type de menaces que je trouve
très désagréable c'est ce qui s'exerce
sur votre quotidien sur la vie
professionnelle j'ai eu la chance d'être
protégés par des réseaux elles type de
réseau par des réseaux de gens qui
estiment que c'est plus important de
dire la réalité que de préserver
des secrets d'état qui en fait ne
servent à protéger que les décideurs qui
ont pris les mauvaises décisions des
réseaux masson je n'en dirai pas plus
sur ses réseaux mais mais je les
remercie voilà
vous travaillez chez qui déjà un crédit
mutualistes non un rôle de protection
sociale mais je serais pas d'accord
l'associé à mon activité d'écrivain ou
pour lancer son rapport avec avec
l'activité et jenna
vous comptez pu retravailler avec
l'armée
oui moi j'ai pas de
corriger pas de contentieux avec l'armée
je restais 20 ans dans l'armée terre je
suis parti comme lieutenant colonel vous
disiez tout à l'heure j'ai eu une
carrière extrêmement intéressante dans
l'armée j'ai été très bien traité dans
le dans le système militaire
j'allais dire en riant parfois mieux que
dans celui des entreprises on se défait
des gens à la vitesse à laquelle on a
voulu les faire venir
je ne fais un camp dire j'ai une très
grande considération pour mes anciens
compagnons d'armes donc mon sujet il
n'est pas du tout avec les militaires
les militaires ont fait ce qu'on leur a
demandé dans des conditions extrêmement
difficiles par contre ce que je trouve
tout à fait inacceptable c'est que sous
prétexte qu'ils sont astreints à
l'obligation de réserve on est axée on
est passé sous silence les faits qu'ils
ont eux même remonter je prends qu'un
exemple
il s'avère que rwanda quand il ya eu le
réarmement dans les camps de réfugiés
les criminels de guerre aient enfin j'ai
gardé des types qui venait de commettre
en fait les massacres
il ya des officiers français qui ont
remonté au plus haut niveau de l'état
que ce n'était pas une bonne idée ou
alors ils l'ont dit avec leurs mots et
ensuite sans landi faut qu'on arrête
c'est pas une bonne politique ça risque
en plus d'initier des années de conflit
dans cette région et on n'a aucune
raison livrer des armes à des criminels
à l'elysée à quelqu'un du plus haut
niveau de l'état
qui avec sa main a fait une petite
mention manuscrite
et l'a écrit appliquer la directive
voilà et ça c'est une des raisons pour
lesquelles les archives sur le rwanda ne
seront jamais ouverte avant que tous les
protagonistes soient morts ça fait 20
ans qu'on me raconte à peu près tous les
deux ou trois ans que il ya plus de
contentieux sur le rwanda d'ailleurs on
va ouvrir les archives donc sous-entendu
n'était pas ouverte avant la dernière
annonce c'est celle du président
françois hollande en 2015 le président
hollande suite d'ailleurs au monde hier
au débat que j'ai essayé d'initier avec
d'autres sur le fait qu'on connaissait
toujours pas la réalité du rôle de la
france au rwanda le président hollande
annonce régis opportunément qu'on va
ouvrir les archives complètement donc
encore une fois j'insiste ça veut dire
contrairement à ce qu'avait dit tous ses
prédécesseurs les archis n'était pas
ouverte mais une fois qu'il a fait ça
son cabinet il a quand même prévenu qu
avant d'ouvrir les archives peut-être
jeter un coup d'oeil sur ce qu'il y
avait à l'intérieur
ils ont dépêché quelques hauts
fonctionnaires pour aller vérifier ça et
c'est eux qui ont rapporté le fait que
je raconte le fait que effectivement il
ya des mentions sur les papiers qu'ils
sont dignes
des meilleurs moments de la
collaboration française moi je n'avais
vu ça que dans des archives de la sncf
ou à l'époque ont marqué on pourrait
mettre 10% de déportés supplémentaires
dans les wagons à bestiaux voilà c'est
de cet ordre là appliquer la directive
ça veut dire qu'il y avait une directive
qui menait la présidence de la
république et qui consistait à remettre
des armes aux personnes qui avaient
commis les massacres de très grande
ampleur encore une fois je pèse mes mots
à l'époque on parle pas de génocide mais
on sait qui a organisé les massacres on
protège leur fuite et on leur livre d
art donc moi j'ai aucun problème avec
les militaires
un sujet il est avec ses responsables
politiques qui ont toujours caché leur
décision et depuis
23 ans maintenant puisque ses 84 ans le
génocide au rwanda chaque fois qu'on
essaye d'évoquer simplement d'initier un
débat ce qui me semble normal dans une
démocratie il le transforme en polémique
sur le thème vous atteignez à l'honneur
de la france moi j'attends à l'honneur
de la france pardon c'est pas l'honneur
de la france que je m'en prends c'est à
leurs responsabilités à ses responsables
là qui ont pris des décisions tellement
inacceptable qu'il n'ose même pas en
parler et pourtant ces décisions elles
existeront toujours parce qu'ils ont
laissé des traces partout est ce que
j'espère c'est qu'un jour c'est archi
seront réellement ouvertes avant tous
les protagonistes soient morts que les
français puissent juger par eux-mêmes
sera pas à moi de juger ce sont en
france est de dire si l'on accepté qu'on
réarme des génocidaires moi je vais
casser vos rêves
le secret défense a été changé on l'a
prolongé je sais pas il y passait de 100
à 150 ans donc j'ai une question nous
avons une question de l'internet on
connaît pas cette histoire doit quand
même posé la question est-ce que vous
avez des infos sur les paras belges
assassiné au rwanda je sais pas si c'est
un ouf je sais pas si c'est quoi que ce
soit
je crois que l'histoire a très clair
parce que en belgique enfin moi j'ai
écouté la commission sénatoriale qui a
enquêté sur
donc le meurtre des dix
belges des dix soldats belges qui
étaient censées protéger la première
ministre et je pense que la lumière a
été faite mais dans une audition
publique il faut imaginer j'invite les
gens à regarder les minutes de l'époque
c'est extraordinaire d'entendre la
manière dont les belges ont interrogé
les officiels de l'époque pour savoir ce
qui s'était passé l'ast et sans
scrupules si je le compare à la mission
parlementaire d'information kida de 98
qui a été mise en place parce qu'un
journaliste courageux patrick de
saint-exupéry qui dit qui est écrit par
don dans le figaro qu'est ce qu'on a
fait au rwanda voilà et du coup très
inquiet le gouvernement de l'époque
décide d'une mission parlementaire
d'information cette mission
parlementaire d'information s'est tenue
quasiment à huit clos pour l'essentiel
est là à mon avis à peu près tout
entendu sauf qu'à l'époque on m'a
demandé de parler témoigner devant mais
bon c'est comme ça mais ce qui est
extraordinaire c'est ses conclusions ces
conclusions c'est il ne s'est rien passé
vous pouvez dormir tranquille il ne
s'est rien passé ce qui est d'autant
plus étonnant c'est que les coprésidents
de cette commission ont refusé de signer
ses conclusions là mais voilà ça ne les
a pas empêchés au plus tôt ça leur a
permis de faire une brillante carrière
derrière ce que je
ce que je regrette c'est que en france
on n'a pas cette tradition
[Musique]
d'examiner sur la table les sujets qui
fâchent on attend en gros que tout le
monde ait disparu pour pouvoir en parler
moi j'ai connu ça avec la guerre
d'algérie quand j'ai été formé dans
l'armée terre il y avait les derniers
représentants dans l'armée des gens qui
avaient connu la guerre d'algérie
c'était impossible d'en parler ils sont
partis quand il sert à l'estomac moi je
fais partie de cette génération qui veut
pas mourir avec ses fantômes mon fantôme
je l'écris dans un livre celui de
sarajevo sur l'irlande a aussi le
suivaient récrire sur le rwanda pour qu'
il soit partagée
et que je puisse le laisser aussi
s'enfuir c'est une bouteille à la mer
pour absoudre votre âme
non c'est pour faire ma part
comment dire c'est pour reconnaître ma
part de responsabilité dans le sujet
g
j'ai parfaitement conscience que dans
toutes ces opérations j'aurais pu
démissionner j'aurais pu m'y opposer
j'ai fait j'ai conduite jusqu'au bout
une manière très professionnelle mais
par contre je veux que la réalité soit
dit voilà c'est quoi la théorie des
baïonnettes intelligente des baïonnettes
intelligente sa part dans les
baïonnettes sont souvent sourde
c'est qu'il ya une capacité de réflexion
et d'intelligence collective qui est
considérable dans l'art mais faut-il
encore l'entendre et l'écouter
après il ya je le disais tout à l'heure
c'est de culture du silence qui est
extrêmement dangereuse qui consiste à
confondre l'obligation de réserve qu'une
obligation professionnelle avec le fait
que non seulement les militaires doivent
faire des saloperies puisque la guerre
c'est une succession de saloperies mais
qu'en plus ils doivent se taire sur ce
qui s'est passé pour ne jamais gêner les
décisions politiques qui ont été prises
à l'époque ça c'est pas acceptable
on repart au 21ème siècle la syrie je
vous donne un petit coup d'oeil au
passage un lacis la veille l'ukraine
l'afghanistan le yémen
l'embrasement de la ceinture
méditerranéenne votre votre avis de
militer sur ce qui se passe en bâbord
mon chien l'ancien militaire quand j'ai
pas forcément elle est toujours très
très bas et non sur le colonel mon
lieutenant quand on l'est toujours
surtout quand on a fait du terrain
on avis est assez mitigé d'abord je
trouve qu'on militarise beaucoup trop le
conflit avec les terroristes le
terrorisme est une forme de guerre mais
ce n'est pas une guerre militaire on
n'envoie pas des parachutistes ou des
avions de chasse quand des terroristes
le fait qu'on se bat en syrie combarde
en libye un camp c'est indispensable
c'est pas ça la guerre contre le
terrorisme la guerre contre le
terrorisme c'est beaucoup plus complexe
et j'ai été outré par les propos de
quelques hommes politiques sur ce sujet
des membres ont appelé à faire la guerre
au terrorisme comme si on allait envoyer
un porte-avions et que avec quatre
frappes aériennes on allait en finir
avec ça je pense que la réalité nous a
rapidement rappelé à l'ordre le
terrorisme c'est une forme de menace
extrêmement diffuse qui peut mettre en
péril le fonctionnement même de notre
démocratie
tout ce qu'on accepte aujourd'hui parce
qu'on est sous la pression des attentats
terroristes en termes de limitation des
libertés individuelles du contrôle
démocratique du contrôle de la justice
sur un certain nombre de procédures
demain ou après demain on s'apercevra
que les effets collatéraux ont été
encore plus considérable que ceux des
armes à uranium appauvri c'est à dire
que il se passera peu de temps avant que
on espionne où on empêche de parler pour
des raisons qu'ils n'auront aucun
rapport avec le terrorisme d'ailleurs
qui pourra dire que c'est pour lutter
contre le terrorisme qu'on aura fait
telle chose et je pense qu'il faut qu'on
soit dans cette période là on à ces
pressions terroriste très forte il faut
qu'on soit d'une extrême vigilance
vigilance sur le fonctionnement de notre
démocratie
moi je ne tiens pas à ce que des
terroristes limite mon champ
démocratique qu'on se bat contre le
terrorisme va très bien mais que les
terroristes transforme la société et
qu'on devienne une société militarisé ou
en guerre pour moi c'est inacceptable
avant-hier on a eut inventé en guérir
avant-hier on a eu un attentat avorté
sur les champs-elysées
avec un dégagement de fumée
vous avez vu ces images là ou par non
j'ai écouté à la radio mais voilà
j'étais sur le champs elysées le matin
donc c'est toujours impressionnant de se
dire qu'un endroit ça peut frapper
n'importe où je pense que c'est c'est le
propre du terrorisme c'est vraiment de
faire peur parce que si on mais
objectivement dans la balance le nombre
de victimes du terrorisme
c'est assez réduit par rapport à un
conflit prend le cas à sarajevo dix
mille morts quand on a des centaines de
morts dus au terrorisme maintenant en
france peut dire c'est épouvantable pour
les victimes mais c'est très peu dans un
conflit par contre le sentiment de peur
d'agressivité que cela peut développer
est extrêmement dangereux moi ce que je
crains le plus dans les attentats
terroristes ces les idiots en france qui
vont décider de se protéger tout seul
d'aller s'en prendre aux autres que chez
boulanger du coin qui est responsable de
sa voix lasse et c'est eux qui font peur
à mon avis là la vraie menace du
terrorisme c'est sur le fonctionnement
de notre société vous voyez pas une
société un peu comme en suisse avec des
milices
on va prendre l'exemple de la suisse
j'ai beaucoup de respect pour les
suisses vis de ce très bon camarade
suisse ils ont
alors aujourd'hui ils ont beaucoup
réduit 1 leurs milices mais ils ont une
des milices les plus importantes
d'europe voire du monde
et ils se sont jamais engagés dans aucun
conflit étranger donc tout ça pour ça
bon voilà poursuivre un autre but mais
je pense que ce n'est pas vraiment un
exemple quoi c'est pas le fait qu'on
fasse appel à des réservistes dans la
police dans l'armée c'est sûrement une
très bonne idée c'est pas à moi d'en
décider mais je trouve que c'est tout à
fait jouable le fait qu' on raconte que
pour lutter contre le terrorisme on va
envoyer quatre mirage 2000 en syrie là
c'est prendre les français pour des
idiots voilà
lise réalisation de notre société qu'est
ce que vous en pensez
je ne souhaite pas je pense que pour la
société israélienne de vivre dans un
sentiment d'insécurité permanent c'est
juste épouvantable et d'ailleurs voilà
je pense qu il
qu'on fasse tout pour éviter d'en
arriver là mais malheureusement leur
société elle est à installer dans un
système complètement paranoïaque où on
sa graisse et on se défend en permanence
à nous de faire en sorte que ça n'arrive
pas votre avis sur une question
d'internet
votre avis sur l'état d'urgence dans
l'état dans le droit commun pardon très
dangereux très dangereux pourquoi et je
pense qu'il faut être très vigilant
parce que justement l'état d'urgence
devient un état normal ce qu'on a envie
de vivre dans un état d'urgence je vais
prendre qu'un exemple quand complètement
idiot anecdotique mais je suis mal
entendants je suis très agressés par les
bruits est-ce que vous avez remarqué que
depuis qu'on est dans l'état d'urgence
on entend en permanence des sirènes
naturel peuple alors c'est bien c'est
pour donner des signes j'imagine qu'il
ya des consignes qui ont été données
tout à l'heure je vais me faire marcher
sur le brûler sur les pieds par une
bagnole choix kelly avec un conducteur
d'accord qui avait sorti son gyrophare
qui était vendu bas dans la rue en la
vie lui était plus dangereux que
l'endroit où ils allaient à mon sens il
allait plutôt récupérer quelqu'un qui
était en retard que agir sur une action
d'urgence voilà jeu juste gêné de ces
espèces de démonstration qu'on veut
faire qui sont qui nous installe dans un
climat de peur et d'insécurité je pense
qu'au contraire les français ont besoin
d'être rassuré tous les français ont
besoin d'être rassurés je suis beaucoup
plus en confort quand une communauté
musulmane par exemple décide à les
surveiller la sécurité des églises je
vais y là c'est un vrai sujet de société
désire on prend soin des uns des autres
et on s'occupe des autres les
manifestations de ce type est bon pour
moi c'est de la fumée quoi ça n'a pas de
sens puis un moment ça devient un peu
pénible vous croyez en dieu
je vais pas répondre à cette question
pourquoi
ça ça me regarde croyant quelque chose
oui ans beaucoup de choses
beaucoup de personnes
est un philosophe à nous donner
non à en particulier plusieurs un oui
sans doute alors trois au moins
non des poèmes
quand je parle quand je partais en
opération j'emportais mille et un ans de
poésie française voilà parce que c'est
souvent dans la poésie conte s'échappe
de la violence
est pas fou info on a un très bon copain
du cnes qui aiment les poèmes et qui dit
qu'il sortira de ce monde où l'action
n'est pas sûr du rêve
question d'internet au nom de quels
intérêts les armées françaises restent
engagés en afrique donc ça c'est une
question pour en revenir dessus en gros
je vous laisse y répondre
la question est intéressante parce que
il ya toujours un sujet de françafrique
il ya une tradition avec laquelle on n'a
jamais rompu totalement même si encore
une fois tous les deux ans on annonce
que ça y est c'est fini mais encore une
fois tous les deux ans l'annoncent donc
ça veut dire qu'on n'a jamais terminé on
a une relation malsaine dans nos
interventions avec l'afrique et je vais
prendre un seul aspect
regardons comment nos
partenaires européens nous regardent
avec réticences quand on leur explique
on va essayer de faire des choses
ensemble en terme de défense à cause de
notre politique d'intervention en
afrique il la trouve tellement opaques
qui se disent c'est impossible d'avoir
des vraies initiatives de sécurité
défense avec des français qui de toute
façon ne disent jamais ce qu'ils vont
faire voilà donc je pense qu'il faudrait
pour moi c'est à ça c'est un sujet très
politique qu'on se met au clair sur
pourquoi on intervient dans ce genre de
zotti quels sont les intérêts poursuit
et du coup seulement à mon avis on
pourra entamer une coopération saine au
sein de l'union européenne
avec des pays qui ont une autre
tradition que la nôtre on continue
d'agir en afrique parce que c'est notre
cannes économique parce que c'est notre
cannes économique
ouais je en partie c'est sûrement une
des raisons il y en a une autre qui
à mon sens c est très malsaine c'est que
contre les chinois non pas du tout on
leur apprendra complet un truc lutter
contre les anglo saxons c'est ce qu'on
nous raconte au rwanda à lutter contre
l' influence anglo-saxonne fachoda et
empêcher de et c'est ma vie c'est pas
tout à fait vrai la réalité pour moi il
est plutôt que les français s'arroge
souvent un rôle ou une responsabilité
que les autres ne leur ont pas demandé
voilà on a beaucoup de mal à s'inscrire
dans des vrais pas un partenariat c'est
à dire à partir justement dans le cas
d'une mission de l'onu officiellement on
avait un mandat de l'onu quand on était
intervenue au rwanda mais en fait on
décide tout seul et quand je dis tout
seul c'est pas les français ces quelques
responsables politiques de la politique
qu'on va mener ils l'expliquent pas aux
français par contre et nous demande de
l'assumer voilà ça je trouve ça anormal
alors autre question d'internet rwanda
2.1 peut-on imaginer telles pratiques de
transmission d'armes envers les actuels
réseaux terroristes alors ça doit parler
de la syrie parce qu'à votre avis en
syrie en armes les gens qui se découpe
qui mangent des fois devant la caméra
qui est un nazi des petits lapins dans
des aquariums qui jette des homosexuels
du neuvième étage d'un bâtiment public
qui lapide les femmes qui vont je vous
passe les détails de troncs avoir nous
aussi on a accès aux images de terrain
autre avis la france armes mais
terroriste
côté syrien libyen
je me souviens que mes camarades qui
sont encore aux affaires à au ministère
la défense aux affaires étrangères ils
ont été très déchirée quand on était
intervenu contre assad en syrie parce
que d'un côté il ya ceux qui disaient
c'est un monstre mais au moins les
pertes sont limitées on alimente pas le
terrorisme international et ce qu'il
disait il faut vraiment se débarrasser
de ce type est un monstre et il faut que
la syrie connaît son histoire y compris
si elle doit passer par des violences
donc on est en permanence justement dans
cette espèce de paradoxe entre on laisse
faire un kadhafi et puis un moment on
décide de le détruire sans avoir rien
prévu et on s'aime un chaos absolument
inimaginable moi je pense que la
solution elle est surtout beaucoup sur
le fait qu' il faut arrêter de raisonner
seul il faut raisonner dans un cadre
communautaire l'union européenne pour
moi est une garantie que d'abord il y
aura un vrai objectif partagé sur ce
qu'on pourrait faire et une garantie
aussi que ce qu'on fait correspond à ce
qu'on dit ça ça changera quelque chose
mais l'europe de la défense c'est une
veste chimère c'est une chimère la
défense entend plein nous parler de
l'europe de la défense mais
qui qui va avoir l'argent pour mettre au
pouce et 2% de pib dans dans la guerre
les budgets réuni de telfrance de toute
l'union européenne sont déjà qu'elle
serait quasiment le premier budget
militaire du monde donc euh pardon mais
c'est plein de talent elle de jay de les
manger bouger la défense oui même en
gagnant 1,8 pour cent alors je parle pas
de l'effort américain actuel qui va bien
j'ai mangé mon deux fois mais pour les
industries la défense mais mais l'union
européenne quand toutes les nations
membres se réunissent pour faire quelque
chose elles ont une puissance qui est
extraordinaire il ya que la grande
bretagne pour vouloir s'en retirer mais
voilà c'est enfin je ne pense pas qu'on
puisse demain à mener une action
pertinente sans échapper à ce niveau 2
comment dire de coopération la guerre c
p
non la guerre c'est la destruction
mener une guerre je crois qu'aujourd'hui
tout le monde en est conscient même si
on a on a le sentiment qu'on n'a pas
connu de guerre depuis la deuxième
guerre mondiale en fait on a été en
permanence en guerre en permanence
impliqués dans des conflits et
je crois pas qu'ils aient plus violents
et destructeurs qu'une guerre je crois
que ce qui m'a marqué c'est l'expérience
au cambodge alors qu'ils sortaient d'une
guerre civile a rien de pire qu'une
guerre civile au fond
il faut presque attendre que la
génération qui a connu la guerre
disparaissent pour pouvoir retrouver une
sérénité dans la société je croirais il
n'y a rien de pire une guerre civile et
quand on peut éviter une guerre c'est
sans doute beaucoup mieux
donc encore une question d'internet
l'armée est elle au courant des intérêts
économiques point d'interrogation
ressources matières premières pendant
d'interrogation ont tout de suite c'est
oui mais je vous laisse déployer votre
raisonnement
je dirais plutôt c'est non vraiment
pardon on veut parler je pense que c'est
non parce que c'est par jeudi qu'un mot
yellow cake
jeudi de maux je pense que d'abord il
faut imaginer que un militaire c'est
c'est aussi un citoyen donc aujourd'hui
il a accès à toutes les sources
d'information il va sur le net même
quand il est en opération et voit plein
de choses il est plein de choses il il a
accès à une information très libre mais
en tant que corps constitués on ne
demande pas à l'armée d'avoir des débats
sur les ressources économiques ou sur
l'intérêt géostratégique du rwanda et
c'est tant mieux gérer dans une
démocratie se trouvera un signe anormal
que ce soit des officiers généraux aux
consorts qui décide qu'on intervient au
rwanda mais pas au tchad donc c'est aux
pouvoirs politiques que ça appartient et
ça me va très bien comme ça donc c'est à
eux deux ils et d'un essai l'intérieur
politique fait forfaiture qu'est ce qui
se passe qu'est l'île devant de notre
hargne
encore une fois c'est pas aux militaires
d'en décider eux ils sont détenteurs du
monopole de la violence d'état et donc
ils n'ont pas à décider la manière dont
on doit l'utiliser alors on irait
immédiatement
via une forme de tyrannie que je peux
pas accepter que d'ailleurs je n'ai
jamais vu traverser l'esprit d'officiers
5 mai mais par contre
le fait que des sources militaires
alimente les cercles de décision
politique justement sur des intérêts qui
peuvent nous apparaître un petit peu
contradictoire ça à mon avis c'est
important d'avoir aussi ce point de vue
des risques est très étonnant il faut
reprendre les débats de l'époque de
kennedy au moment où ils apprennent aux
états unis que les russes ont installé
des missiles à cuba en fait si on
reprend les minutes de discussion dans
son cercle très réduit pour l'essentiel
ce sont des officiers généraux qui
essaye de le convaincre de short ou pas
bombarder des armes nucléaires à cuba et
ce sont des faucons ceux qui sont jamais
battus et qu'ils n'ont jamais perdu deux
camarades au combat qui explique que ce
serait très bien de vulcanisé cuba sous
deux mètres de profondeur voilà c'est
juste un exemple que je dois organiser
se le dire a indiqué et sur le tchat
paraît-il que vous avez pas répondu à
une question sur l'armement des
terroristes
mais enfin je pensais l'avoir fait donc
je complète c'est clair qu'il ya des
situations très délicates sur lesquels
pour soutenir un moment un mouvement on
comment dire on regrette amèrement
d'avoir livré un certain nombre d'un
souvenons nous nous souvenons nous de la
manière dont les américains ont soutenu
les talibans pendant la première guerre
d'afghanistan et dont les armes se sont
assez rapidement retournée contre nos
doigts c'est toujours très compliqué de
soutenir un mouvement parce qu'au fond
personne ne sait prédire l'avenir et
donc mesurer les dommages collatéraux de
qu'est-ce qu'on a livrée maintenant si
on regarde la réalité à l'époque les
américains livrer des stingers aux
talibans pour mettre en difficulté
l'armée russe qu'ils ont jamais raconté
ses castings heures et une espérance de
vie très limitée parce que ces normes
assez sophistiqué et si elle n'est pas
entretenue par des vrais industriels de
l'armement au bout de deux ans ça
fonctionne plus voilà les pas qu'on
l'ait pas le dire mais on s'est
vachement interrogé sur qu'est ce qu'on
fait quand on livre des armes
sophistiquées ou des armes du terrorisme
parce qu'un missile sol air portables
c'est une arme de terroristes à des
factions comme ça totalement
incontrôlable on pourrait vous montrer
une vidéo d'un stock de 2 me soler en
syrie avec du français dans les
parterres bon passons et
question est ce que vous connaissez le
groupe surcouf alors ça me dit rien est
ce que vous avez entendu parler que
certains généraux français ont été mis
sur et que ceux mis sur écoute non non
autre question je ne les ai pas entendus
groupe surcouf collège interarmées de
défense transformé en école de guerre
enseignez vous parle a peut-être vous
verrez le nom du général desportes
l'hectare et encore je connais le
général vincent desportes
donc qu'à quitter l'armée 1 qui enseigne
en maintenant notamment à sciences po
alors je sais pas s'il a été mis sur
écoute cayman elle m'en a pas parlé
c'est surtout un extraordinaire des
batteurs et justement sur le sujet que
j'évoquais tout à l'heure c'est là que
ça fait partie de ces hommes d'horizons
qui disent la culture du silence
n'apporte rien dans nos systèmes
démocratiques j'ai apporté de l'eau à
votre moulin du temps où l'école de
guerre s'appelait encore collège
interarmées de défense ou le général
desportes était président
on n'a jamais eu à se plaindre en tant
que civil de notre liberté d'expression
au sein des murs du collège interarmées
de défense
autre question d'internet en cas de
révolution entre guillemets populaire
visant à rétablir une démocratie via une
constituante senti l'armée prête à
soutenir ce type de mouvement radical
en gros est ce que l'armée sera derrière
le peuple si ça commence à chauffer
qu'entre l'état je pense qu'il ya une
légère confusion
[Musique]
l'armée n'est pas un corps qui agit par
lui-même et heureusement que l'armée ça
fait partie des grands services de
l'état et elle est aux ordres de l'état
le jour où l'armée décidera de se
révolter contre l'état sait qu'on sera
arrivé dans l'ain en état alors que
l'état n'aura plus aucune légitimité qui
se sera détruit tout seul qu'il aura
imploser j'ai entendu des discours
politiques hallucinant dimanche après
les élections sur le fait que l'état
n'était plus légitime et c'est
apparemment il ya eu des élections des
élections relativement réglo enfin je
n'ai pas entendu qu'il y avait eu
malversations sur ces élections donc il
faut accepter le verdict des urnes après
on peut regretter qu'ils aient un taux
d'abstention qui essaiera mais n'y a pas
de sujet pour moi sur la légitimité de
l'état d'aujourd'hui si demain
imaginons que l'état français soit très
contesté j'espère que le dernier service
qui décideraient tout seul de faire
quelque chose contre l'état soit l'armée
c'est pas à eux d'agir repas petit
putsch surcoût pas mince alors
alors dès avant dernière question
hop hop hop très bien que pense-t-il de
l'intérêt du ca vient d'internet encore
que pense-t-il de l'arrêt du service
militaire en france pour contre la
réinstauration votre avis sur la rai
d'abord c'est une question qui date un
peu ça fait maintenant ça fait 20 ans
qu'elle a été décidée et ça doit faire
une quinzaine d'années qu'elle est
effective moi j'ai connu la transition à
ce que je m'occupais des
restructurations moment la
professionnalisation de l'armée en
nettement entre eux un système qui
n'employaient pour l'essentiel
que
comme on pourrait appeler ça des
travailleurs temporaires et puis un
système il ya que des professionnels il
n'y a pas photo sur la technicité sur
l'entraînement sur la formation sur
gilles pargneaux pardon sur le coup
alain le coût est en proportion c'est à
dire que comme on est resté dans le même
budget c'est ça qui nous a obligé à
réduire des deux tiers le format de
l'armée et sauf que aujourd'hui on a une
armée qui est plus réduite que celle
qu'on a connue du temps la conscription
mais qui est totalement utilisable alors
qu'au fond avance et les créances du
golfe qu'il a montrées on avait une
armée pléthorique mais dont 10% à peine
était engage à bhl on voit là c'est pour
moi c'est un choix de raison c'est à
dire que si on veut avoir des miliciens
entre guillemets donc du personnel
temporaire qui donne un peu de son temps
c'est sûrement envisageable dans des
conditions très particulières sur des
missions à trop complexes du type garde
etc et à condition d'avoir une vraie
structure derrière qu'il a il faut pas
se faire d'illusions coûte très cher
parce que entretenir ce genre de
l'équipe les suisses l'an payer fort
cher d'ailleurs c'est pour ça qu'ils ont
énormément réduit leurs milices tout ça
est extrêmement coûteux alors forcément
quand il ya une vague d'attentats on a
tous envie qui est des centaines de
militaires dans la rue mais rappelons
nous que six mois après
on s'en souvient et que là quand on voit
le budget de l'état affiché en dire bah
non faut pas dépenser autant donc il
faut être raisonnable à mon avis sur
l'outil militaire dont on a besoin et je
me permets d'insister sûr ce point comme
aujourd'hui la principale menace
terroriste pas oublier que la réponse à
la menace terroriste n'est pas militaire
l'armée est une toute petite partie de
la réponse à la menace terroriste à mon
avis elle est beaucoup plus sur les
sujets renseignements de société
démocratie y compris peut-être de
formation de capacité à comprendre
comment fonctionne une communauté à
s'assurer d'avoir de vrais relais à
l'intérieur enfin voilà il ya il ya
autre chose que d'aller acheter la
dernière génération de flingues
donc dit avant dernière question mais je
vais en prendre une dernière
frappe pour contribuer à tuer combien de
personnes a alors je me sens assez
légers sur le sujet puisqu'on m'a
empêché de frapper à sarajevo donc a
priori
nous par les frappes aériennes nous
n'avons tué personne par contre le fait
que nous n'ayons pas frapper
a laissé des centaines de morts dans
sarajevo c'est plutôt ça que je regrette
j'aurais aimé frappé et je le dis sans
aucun scrupule j'étais avec une équipe
de pros on aurait payé pour pouvoir le
faire parce que c'était totalement
justifiée est ce que je ne comprends pas
aujourd'hui 23 ans après c'est les
raisons pour lesquelles on ne l'a pas
fait mais le grade mais de belgrade les
frappes qui ont été faits par l'otan à
belgrade mais c'était n'importe quoi il
y avait des gars qui faisaient des
manifestations des des civils qu'ils
aient des manifestations pour éviter qu
on dézingue l'époux à belgrade ils ont
dézingué la télé publique il ya eu des
gamins qui sont faits ravagé une télé
publique avec des journalistes
les journalistes
je parlais de sarajevo en 95 ans je n'ai
pas parlé des frappes de l'otan après
sur la yougoslavie au palais pour moi ça
travaille sur les frappes de l'otan
g
je pense qu'elles ont été très
destructrice et qu'en même temps elles
ont permis
d'accéder très très vite à une situation
de négociation les serbes sont allées
très rapidement à la table de
négociation pardon parce qu'ils ont été
très brutalement un traité et vu la
manière dont il avait traité avant les
autres populations de la yougoslavie
je peux pas juger de l'histoire je pense
que le retour qu'ils ont eue c'était
quand même un petit peu les graines de
violence qu'ils avaient semé dans toute
la yougoslavie
faut-il être plus buru que le bourg où
surtout pas
donc totalement opposé à la peine de
mort
dernière question qui ont qui est
commune tous nos invités laissez un
question de laisser un conseil pour les
jeunes générations une bouteille à la
mer quelque chose d'impérissables qui va
rester sur internet
c'est à vous
c'est une question difficile pour moi il
ya il ya un point qui est crucial dans
le témoignage que j'ai voulu apporter
dans ce que j'ai essayé de raconter
aujourd'hui c'est l'exigence
démocratique la démocratie n'est que le
fruit de notre exigence donc plus on se
laisse imposer des solutions ou
expliquer ce qu'on doit penser d'une
situation et plus on s'éloigne de notre
propre liberté
guillaume ancel merci
on goûte
on a coupé au golf
prochain direct prochain directeur de
bilan
[Musique]
dans
e